leur confinement comme réponse à
l'aggravation de la crise sanitaire
sera-t-il un coup de grâce pour
l'économie le premier confinement
s'était soldée par une chute historique
de l'activité aux conséquences
désastreuses
un choc dont l'économie commençait tout
juste à se remettre alors la france
peut-elle en supporter un deuxième avec
quel coût économique et social
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bienvenue
jacques bonjour olivier alors jacques
leur confinement en vigueur depuis une
semaine maintenant nous renvoie t-il à
la situation du printemps dernier oui
absolument si d'ailleurs on veut bien
écouter ce qu'on me dit que ce soit
jérôme salle au moment où le ministre de
la santé
mais on sait aussi que tout ton film en
aura des conséquences graves que ses
conséquences soient économique social
sanitaire ou psychologique c'est
pourquoi on sent bien que le
gouvernement si on regarde les mesures
veut désespérément ne pas tuer
l'activité et pourtant les mesures qui
sont prises dès ma certitude qui règne
autour de ces menus de ces mesures aura
de toutes les manières des conséquences
extrêmement négative et profondément
durable sur l'activité économique
alors jacques peut-on estimer ses
conséquences oui tout à fait les mesures
de couvre-feu qui avaient été prises il
ya maintenant en plus de quinze jours on
savait qu'elle allait coûter grosso modo
1 % de croissance à l'économie française
avec les nouvelles mesures
on estime que le coût sera au minimum de
2 % et si ces mesures devaient être un
petit peu prolongé dans le temps
assis confinement devait durer un peu
plus que quatre semaines et bien on
pourrait monter jusqu'à 4% alors c'est
important parce qu'il faut savoir que
avant le confinement avant le couvre-feu
on était déjà pratiquement à 10 % de
chute de la production pour l'année 2020
et on voit en particulier sur un
graphique qui mélange à la fois des
données qui sont réalisés par le fonds
monétaire international et
des données et qui ont été recalculées
dans mon laboratoire on voit que en
fonction des hypothèses que ce soit
quatre semaines huit semaines
où que ce soit justement une
prolongation avec un possiblement une
troisième vague au printemps
eh bien on atteint des résultats qui
sont bien plus mauvais alors d'ailleurs
depuis ce confinement les protestants
les commerçants par l'ong proteste
beaucoup oui oui et non sans raison
d'ailleurs ce nouveau coup d'arrêt sera
fatale à un grand nombre de pme cela il
n'y a pas moins de 200 milles commerces
qui ont été fermées administrativement
et on le sait que beaucoup n'y
résisteront pas
pourtant on disait que l'économie était
en train de se redresser
oui tout à fait effectivement l'activité
économique avait semblé se redresser de
rendre cet été seulement il faut savoir
que l'insee indiquait il ya quelques
jours déjà que cette reprise de
l'activité fléchit c'est déjà en
septembre est nettement plus mois
d'octobre même chose si on regarde le
graphique
eh bien on voit que les commandes de
biens durables commencé à baisser en
septembre 2020 par exemple les dépenses
de consommation des ménages en biens
s'était fortement repliée et on voit que
ce repli provient essentiellement de la
baisse importante des achats de biens
fabriqués de biens manufacturés
un chiffre qui a baissé d'environ 7%
donc il est évident que tout cela
repousse et déjà le redressement total
de l'économie bien au delà de 2024 et
est ce que l'on peut détailler par
secteur d'activité lac
oui oui bien entendu
alors d'abord il ya évidemment le
secteur du commerce à ça on l'a dit mais
il faut savoir que cet impact sur le
secteur du commerce aura évidemment des
conséquences sur l'industrie qui fournit
les biens qui sont vendus par le
commerce et donc sur la production et
sur l'emploi se lance il sera pas le
seul
évidemment le secteur du tourisme et de
la restauration sont aussi sinistrée on
peut étendre ce raisonnement au secteur
du transport aérien et aéronautique
d'ailleurs les commandes d'airbus sont
passés de 776 avion en 2019
seulement 300 cette année et enfin il ya
toujours la question du télétravail en
garde sur le gouvernement veut favoriser
le télétravail mais on sait très bien
que les entreprises sont très réticentes
et pour une raison très simple c'est que
le télétravail amoindri la productivité
et donc en réalité amoindri la
production à mais le gouvernement entend
bien prendre de nouvelles mesures de
soutien en we are oui absolument
le fait que les commerces de puisse plus
vendre un souffle et les commerces de
produits alimentaires et qui plus est
dans une période où ça va être noël
évidemment on s'attend à ce que les
ventes soient très importante bien tout
cela va créer une crise de trésorerie
très importante dans les tpe et dans les
commerces une crise que le gouvernement
cherche à éviter par des mesures
spécifiques
alors ces mesures on sait qu'elles
comprennent la prise en charge de 10000
euros par mois de la perte de chiffre
d'affaires des tpe pme qui ont été
fermées administrativement
il y aura des mesures de prêts pour
soutenir justement ces entreprises en ce
qui concerne les chars et les loyers à
payer dans cette période et enfin on
parle beaucoup d'un plan pour les
indépendants les commerçants et les tpe
mais là encore il faut faire attention
parce que d'abord les prêts ce n'est pas
de l'argent direct et puis ensuite parce
que le gouvernement n'a pas détaillé son
plan spécial et surtout n'a pas abordé
le sujet des pertes d'exploitation qui
sera un sujet évidemment très important
dans les semaines qui viennent
et selon vous agace que le gouvernement
a pêché finalement par manque
d'anticipation
oui oui je je pense que c'était tout à
fait évident alors on le voit déjà avec
la manière dont le gouvernement n'avait
pas prévu cette fronde des commerçants
et la fronde des maires inquiets eu lieu
le week-end dernier au delà mais quand
emmanuel macron utilise des métaphores
militaires arrivera nous sommes en
guerre comme en mars dernier où quand
ils utilisent l'expression de couvre-feu
est tout simplement il a oublié ou
peut-être n'at-il jamais su comment
gagner une guerre vous savez à olivier
une guerre ça se gagne en constituant
des réserves que ce soit en sommes au
matériel et se sont serrés
vers justement qui peuvent être engagées
quand la situation se des crabes comme
aujourd'hui donc il fallait dès le
printemps dernier
commencer à penser à la constitution de
ces réserves que ce soit en lit on
respire à tort ou en personnel justement
et accumulé juste des moyens qui
pourraient être engagés maintenant quand
on voit que emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement mais ils sont restés
fidèles à un modèle de gestion lui
inadapté et je dois dire que au delà des
erreurs qui ont des commises dans la
gestion au jour le jour de l'épidémie
c'est probablement là que se situe
l'erreur la plus grave et du coup quels
seront les effets durent confinement sur
les inégalités
si vous voulez il est évident que tout
confinement accroît les inégalités
alors vous avez un rapport du conseil
d'analysé économique qui a été fait il
ya quelques jours et qui établit par
exemple que dans l'épargné importante
qu'on a cumulé les français on parle
autour de 55 milliards de route et bien
grosso modo 70% de cette épargne sont
réalisés par les 20% les plus riches
a contrario les 50 % les plus pauvres
les dd des ménages
eh bien eux ils ont vu leur épargne
diminué donc il ya déjà une égalité de
revenus évidente et puis il ya toutes
les autres inégalités comme les
inégalités de logements les inégalités
qui viennent dans la répartition du
travail est là dessus est aussi une note
de la direction du trésor qui détaille
la totalité de ces inégalités oui on
peut dire que le compliment c'est un
accélérateur des inégalités il va donc
falloir s'attendre à un quatrième
semestre noir
oui oui c'est aujourd'hui une évidence
le choc de ce deuxième confinement sera
lourd alors entre 2 et 4% du pipe c'est
évident bien sûr un choc aussi en
matière de chômage
on peut penser que le chômage va
augmenter en plus de ce qu'il a devait
augmenter avec les effets du premier
confinement de 200 mille voire trois
cent mille personnes et donc on aura un
recul de la production qui va se situer
entre -12 et -14%
pour cette année par ailleurs il est
très clair que l'on ne retrouvera pas le
niveau de 2019 en 2023 ce qui étaie
l'hypothèse du gouvernement mais qu'il
faudra attendre très probablement 2025
c'est considérable
mais il faut savoir que ce n'est pas le
pire ce n'est pas le pire que voulez
vous dire par l'ajac
mais si vous voulez le pire c'est que
l'incertitude qui est engendrée par la
situation actuelle
justement par cette deuxième vague et
par le fait qu'on se demandait ce
qu'elle ne sera pas suivie à près d'une
troisième vannes
et bien cette incertitude est les
meurtrières pour tous les projets
d'investissement que ce soit les projets
d'investissement des entreprises
mais que ce soit aussi les projets
d'investissement des ménages
or si vous voulez c'est l'investissement
privé qui est d'une certaine manière
l'un des moteurs avec la consommation
bien entendu de l'activité économique
si on a pas d'investissement eh bien ça
veut dire qu'il n'aura pas de véritable
reprise en 2021 2022 war 2023 c'est pour
ça qu'il est tout à fait capital
aujourd'hui que l'investissement publics
prennent massivement le relais de cet
investissement privé qui sera défaillant
du fait de l'incertitude et que l'on
aille bien au delà du plan de relance
qui a été annoncé plan de relance qui
s'avère désormais obsolète et
tragiquement insuffisant il faut bien le
dire
alors le gouvernement à vous entendre et
donc au pied du mur merci en tout cas on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
jacques